Hello, everyone.
Um, I'm Ambuj Gupta
from uh PWC, uh, director
in AI engineering.
Um, with me today we have,
uh, Kevin as well
who's, uh, uh, also from, uh,
PWC director in AI engineering,
uh, Nafi and, uh, Nafi and Wale
who are from the automated, uh,
uh, reasoning team who actually helped with
this overall solution.
So today we are gonna talk about
how we are, uh.
Utilizing automated reasoning in addition
to bedrock, uh, to bring
a more accurate and verifiable answers,
uh, to different inquiries, be it be, uh,
any sector.
So, uh, let me get into that.
So let's talk about that, uh, why
did we
Why did we come up with automated reasoning? Uh,
what is automated reason and why do we
need it when we already have guard rails,
right? So,
We all know that in the last many
years, a couple of years, we have seen tremendous
progress with respect to LLM's Gen AI,
and we have seen
it is spanning in all the dimensions and horizons
with the
greatest speed,
but one consistent problem we have seen all
the time is that the accuracy of the
answers and ha hallucination, as you can
see here
uh. The hallucination
part is the toughest uh
uh outcome of that where it is
creating a lot of problem if we are
dealing with customer service industry, if you're
dealing with the
industry where accurate answers are more
important,
then it becomes a problem when we don't have
a solution for that um in a
timely manner, right?
So
to do that, uh.
Uh, we have, uh, Amazon,
uh, automated reasoning which works automatically
with the,
uh, in the guardrail space
where it works to ensure that the answers
are accurate, which means that it identifies
and suggests
why this answer is correct and based
on what factual knowledge.
Secondly, that it checks for the soundness,
which means that
whether this answer is derived
logically based on verifiable
information or is it something else
because it always comes back with three types of
responses number 1, whether the answer
is valid or not.
Number 2.
Um, if it's not valid, why it's
not valid? And number 3, it never pretends.
It will say that, hey, I don't know if
the answer
is, uh, valid or invalid. And, in
addition to that, it just doesn't come back with
a couple of, uh, responses. It
provides recommendation that should we ask more
questions to,
uh, the customer, maybe information is missing
or, uh, we should pass
this information for another scenario
where we can, uh, present a different answers
to the customers,
right? So let me
get to the next one, right?
Lastly, that with the responsible AI
um implementation,
we need to make sure that any answer which is
provided is, uh.
Explainable and uh there is
transparency in that and it consistent
with respect to any channel if customer is
reaching out to us with automated reasoning
all this happened because uh as I was saying,
guardless, they have uh limitations
where you can do content filtering, you can do
topic filtering, but after that
what we cannot do at the scale is that
implementing the business rules and this is
where automated reasoning comes into the
picture to ensure that we are able to utilize
these business rules or a standard operating procedure,
be it any industry.
Uh, pharmaceutical
or, um, uh, utility
or, uh, financial,
anything where we can have these business rules
that would change
in uh they would vary with different subject
matter but
with this automated reason we are able to scale
it, uh, without a lot of
modifications.
Let me get to the next one.
Yeah. So as
you can see that automated reasoning is the algorithm
search for new mathematical proof. The way
it works is that it derives
the mathematical proof of the rules
and applies them on the answers
which are coming from GAI or LLM
and then provide the answers based on that. And
for that it uses a logical model
and software to explore the states because
it is able to search across a different
or vast state of information as well.
Yeah, let me, let me also specify
that, uh,
automated reasoning is not a new service.
It has been used already in Amazon for
many, many years, right?
So if you go to the next page, you would see that it
has been used for, uh, VPC,
uh, reachability to make sure that
if a connection should be going out or going in,
uh, IMS analyzer, that, that's
how it's able to quickly change the permission
whenever we make the changes in the policy or a
role for a group or anything like that, right?
Uh, ensuring that S3 block public
access, how can we make sure that, uh,
in service, which is our data, which is not
supposed to be exposed publicly,
uh, is, uh, is, um, is managed
accordingly and then utilizing the, uh,
inspector service as well, which is utilizing
the same automated reasoning to
identify different, uh, vulnerability and anomalies
happening in the AC2 instances, right?
Now let us, uh, uh, let me present you,
uh, a one,
diagram where you would be able to see
that how we have been utilizing automated reasoning
with the generative AI. So on the top
you would see that generative AI is providing
answer for uh, all type of uh
questions, right? But as we all know that
there would always be an answer, but
accuracy of it is not guaranteed, right?
Uh, and that's where automated reasoning
comes like a lawyer
who never pretends to know the
information, whether it will say that the information is valid
or it's not valid, or it will
say that, hey, we have to take one of these systems,
maybe ask more questions to the customer,
maybe some information is missing,
or provide some additional annotations because
utilizing those, uh, downstream
lender processes can take corrective actions
or maybe transfer the chat or the call
to a human agent.
Right? And um, uh, in addition
to that, it also provides recommendations
what needs to be done.
So, let me hand it over to Kevin, who will,
uh, look into that. Yeah.
Hello everyone. So
just quickly dialing back to everything that
Ambuj was mentioning here. So
working across different use cases, building
air solutions, different industries,
all regulated.
Now these are probabilistic systems,
so we're very aware that we're producing outcomes
that need to be verified. So essentially we're
not
flying blind. We have metrics such
as faithfulness. We build retrieval augmented
generation. Uh, metrics
that assess quality
that falls into the evaluation,
uh, dimension of the AI
solution development life cycle.
So when AWS came to us and told us
they had this specific service
that gave us an entirely different dimension
which could be brought in,
which could give us auditability and
traceability of what we're building, so.
Primarily what I'm referring to is that,
you know, there is a different branch of mathematics
that could be applied and effectively
verify the solutions that are being.
Produced and the language model outcomes
that are being derived for any solution
that you're building, you're building all of these wrappers on top of
language models, but there is a layer that actually
mathematically verifies this.
Now when PWC started doing
this, we approached it from the lens
of having two different concrete portions.
So whatever Ambuja was describing in terms of that
logical design and then the
answer verification piece is kind of what
we did in these two parts that you
see. You call it policy design
and then verification and testing. So staying
with that for a second here.
The policy design is a key
concept which hasn't necessarily been
approached in this way before
while we were dealing with probabilistic systems,
so you have a bunch of business rules. Language
models are good at understanding those business rules.
You ask models to look at those business
rules, follow them,
and ensure, you know, they're producing a
result in line with those business rules.
The most we used to do was, you know, absolutely
follow these business rules
do not
spell something out if you're unsure about
the solution. That's something that we've always
produced, but how do you
ensure that those results are consistent,
mathematically verifiable and accurate?
So this was, you know,
ringing good news to the ears of all
governance committees that review models
and then pass them through to production, right?
So. They came up with a solution
which first and foremost lets us
define those policies as
logic statements. So logic statements are
basically
statements that use your
uh and operations or
operations, all of your boolean logic that we traditionally
learned in high school, right?
So once we're able to derive them
technically what is supposed to happen,
and again this is where you need full certification
of it
from an actual logician or somebody
who has a PhD in formal methods
looking through those statements and ensuring
that they actually reflect the business rules.
Now what Nafi and Wali and team have created
is a system that's close to 99%
accurate in terms of deriving those policies
as well as verifying them because verification
is a step
where you populate these logic statements
with variables coming in from your language model
outputs.
Say you, if you have X and Y
and then R with like a bunch of other variables,
you fill them in and then you have a true
or false outcome.
That effectively is, you
know, a standardized deterministic
outcome for you to verify if the
model is performing as it's expected
based on some policy that you've laid out and this
becomes paramount in regulated industries,
right? So
that was the key thing that we were able
to derive from the service and we're
starting to sort of
uh. Extrapolate
and apply this to as many use cases as
possible,
so the verify and test bucket that's being
described here is effectively
testing it at training time. So you derived
a bunch of statements you're trying to see if
that applies to your use case and
if it works well enough, you're effectively
progressing it to inference time, which
is the deployment and monitoring solution.
And this is where Ambuch was referring to,
you know, this being applied to security protocols
already within AWS.
So in some sense, AWS is the leader
in this field.
They've already developed formal verification
methods for security protocols, say within
S3
or, you know, judging IM policies
through, you know,
converting. Network topology into
these formal statements but now given
the fact that we have language models this could
broadly be applied to any given use
case that you have.
So that's what we found value
in and we've tested this out
in a few industry applications so one
being pharma content review. So
you're generating content for,
uh, pharma copy in some sense
and you're making sure that that is aligned with
the label,
a bunch of business rules that are
set out by, you know.
Central organizations like the FDA for
example, and then Ambuj will be talking
about utilities outage, which is the other use
case that we're focusing on here.
Uh, there are other use cases like the EU AI
Compliance Act where we're broadly
applying every single use case and
linking it back to the Compliance Act itself.
And then there's some sense of doing this on
cloud security where we're ensuring
that cloud infrastructure is compliant
against a bunch of rules like HIPPAA
or FINRA or something of that sort, right, so.
With that, uh.
Moving back to utilities outage, and I'll let
Ambuch go back.
Thank you. Uh,
thank you, Kevin.
So, uh,
let's talk about the use case, um, uh,
of the utility outage. We all know that,
uh, during outage situation or a storm
situation, uh,
Utility companies, they prepare,
uh, uh, uh really well uh
for situations where uh if customer is
uh losing a power they are able to
respond to that how soon our power will
be back,
how soon they'll be getting the services back,
and, uh, what is the, uh, what are the
like uh uh situations around it, right?
So the way we have been working with other utilities
is that utility they work across the states,
right? And every state has different, uh,
state laws, and they have to follow that.
Now, uh, so far it has
been that he, it is pretty much
determined a way to design these
processes that for one state we have.
A process which says that
a low, low level or maybe a low
priority ticket will be responded or
would be fixed and maybe in 10 to 12
hours, but other places the
uh the ETAs is different, right?
Not to manage all these uh scenarios,
uh, the system.
Have been tightly coupled and built in
a manner that they are doing the job, but when it comes,
uh, for the scalability,
we hit a roadblock, right?
So the problem that we are seeing here is that, uh,
customer who's experiencing a power outage,
they demand that, um,
they are provided response in a quick manner,
um. Inaccurate inconsistency
should not be there at all, right? And
there should be useful self-service options,
right? So they, they know that when the power is coming
back or there's a truck rollout would
happen and then there would be crew at their
location, right?
So to do that, uh, we created, uh, utilizing
Amazon services. We created this
particular, uh, utility outage chatbot.
So what you would see on the top is that,
um.
Outage of standard operating procedures, these
documents, which
which can change based on the states, they are
loaded to automated reasoning,
right? And what automated reasoning does
is that it, it extract all that
information and create mathematical model,
derive different variables, creates rules,
and index those rules, uh, in an efficient
manner, right?
And uh at the bottom you would see
that we have a chatbot which is created
using Amazon services such as Amazon
Lex, uh, Amazon, uh, uh,
Amazon generative VI application,
Bedrock.
We also have Lambda, and also you would see uh
Dynamo DB which is storing the real-time
information about uh the
outage situation.
Different, uh, across different zip code there are
many companies, they offer different version of these
databases,
but this is a NoSQL highly scalable
inform uh information database which is gonna
store all the insights
related to those, uh, those, uh, uh,
locations. So you would see that customer is asking
that, hey, when my, uh, power will
be back or what is the status of the
outage, right?
So generative AI or the AI
would provide an answer, but it that
answer has to be verified,
and that's where,
uh, automated reasoning comes into the picture,
where it looks into the answer and before
it let that answer go to customer, it
checks whether the answer is valid or not, because
as I was saying before, that
a low priority ticket should not be answered. Answered
in 2 hours versus a high priority ticket
or critical situation where someone is dealing with a
life and that situation that should be handled
quickly, right? So we want to make sure that
those, uh, those scenarios
are scalable and you would
see that on the subject matter experts box
that you would see
that they are able to make these changes
live, right? Because during a storm situation
we also have to make validations
and verification that what policy
should or should not exist,
right? Uh
Uh, so, any question at this point, uh, with
respect to this diagram?
OK,
so this makes sense. Uh, seems like everyone
got it. Uh, with that, let me hand it
over to Kevin. He would, uh,
speak about the, uh, design for
pharmaceutical content review.
Yeah, yeah,
uh. So getting back to this
particular use case, uh, we were.
Dealing with the pharmaceutical content review use
case where we looked at
pharmaceutical promotional content and
Judging or ensuring that they were actually
sticking to the rules
that were laid out by the FDA and companies
have their own internal rules that we need to align
with purely for regulatory purposes
first and foremost,
so the flow that you have on the
top is what we develop
basically by instructing the language model,
uh, giving it access to the rules so that it
can produce
judgments on what needs to be
updated within a piece of content.
Now what we found with the flow below
is that it's complementary to what's on
top, right? So
language models are great at language understanding,
so they're producing your outcomes, whereas
formal verification or symbolic logic
gives us a means
to take those statements, actually convert them
into logical statements, and effectively
serve as a second line of defense for
the outcomes that are being produced, right?
So in this case if you ask
us what did we necessarily use
as these rules, certain times you don't have
these rules documented in that
case you could take a perfect example
that you think is already aligned with all of these
rules and you're able to derive rules
out of them as well, those
examples,
so. Just to sort of
close what we're talking about here, this
is again gaining a lot of mainstream momentum
as of last week, well, again,
like I'm describing a fundamental shift in
how we're using probabilistic systems and then
grouping them with deterministic systems
just last week, Deep Seek
Math We do came out and.
They were using
in order to verify mathematical theorems
a verifier which was effectively using
a theorem prover or a solver
that is used within the automated reasoning
service, right? So I mean it's
only probably going to get more ubiquitous
as we, as we're building more and more use
cases here.
Um, happy to take more questions, but I do
want to pass it along to Nafi and Wale to
give us a sense of the roadmap and what they're using this
for, so.
Thank you Kevin.
So I just wanted to reinforce uh
about what both Kevin and Ambush just talked
about to highlight that
even though we're talking about automated reasoning
and about math, it's still like
really we're talking about applying this and
the service is generally available to
the through the Applied guard rail API
and
really what we wanna do is basically
um. Work in terms of common
sense. Like there are a lot of small,
uh, actions or rules that we want
to make sure
that they apply and the idea is that
you can take these rules and turn them
into automated reasoning policy and what
you're really gaining is that now you can
move with confidence, right? You can take
the advantages of uh of generative AI
and be able to move this confidence
so um we're available to help,
you know, feel free to reach out to your account teams
if you have use cases that you would like to, um,
you know, look into the team is available to help.
I'll now pass it over to Wale.
Yeah, thanks Nafi.
Um, I think my colleagues already
said everything. I'm a scientist from AWS.
Um, we've been doing
automated reasoning for about a decade,
and the idea now is to bring deterministic
guarantees to probabilistic systems
because we know LLMs hallucinates
by design
and so with automated reasoning. You can take policies,
you can auto formalize them into logical
statement, build models, and then use
that as a verification layout for your
generative AI applications.
And so yeah, I think if anyone wants to talk to us about
automated reasoning and how to use
it as part of Bedro guard drills, um,
we'll probably wait behind. Thank you everyone.
Thank you.